So, for today's lecture as you
can see up there is molecular --
00:00:08<clear/>
evolution, and ecology.
00:00:16<clear/>
And what I mean by this,
it's basically the study or
what we try to figure out in
molecular evolution and ecology
is what genes or gene sequences
can tell us about the evolution
and ultimately also the ecology
of organisms in the environment.
And it's particularly relevant
for thinking about
microorganisms,
prokaryotes and the
environment.
And I hope I can actually
convince you today of that.
This is interesting.
The topics that I want to cover
today is, first of all,
I want to review a little bit
what we know about life on
Earth, sort of give an overview
of the evolution of life on
Earth.
Then, I want to go into
specific topic that's of
particular relevance for the
evolution of eukaryotes.
That's the endosymbiosis
theory.
And then I'll explain how we
can use gene sequences to
actually reconstruct events that
have happened a very,
very long time ago.
OK, so we'll look at what we
call molecular phylogenies,
with the use of gene sequences
to reconstruct the evolutionary
history of organisms on Earth.
Derived from that,
we'll look at what we call the
tree of life.
That's sort of the big picture
overview of the evolutionary
relationships of all organisms
on the planet.
And then finally,
I'll introduce you to a topic
called molecular ecology.
Again, that's how we can use
gene sequences to learn
something about the diversity of
microorganisms in the
environment that lead us then,
next time, when I come back on
Monday, into this big topic of
environmental genomics,
how we can actually expand this
analysis to learn much more
about organisms in the
environment.
So, first of all,
let's look at life on Earth.
Does anybody know how old we
think Earth is?
Say again?
Yeah, 4.5 to 4.6,
I haven't my notes 4.6.
So, Earth's thought to have
originated about 4.6 billion
years ago.
When did the first solid rocks
appear on earth?
So, when was the surface kind
of solidified?
Anybody know?
About 3.9 billion years ago,
OK?
And when do we think life
started to develop on the
planet?
Any ideas?
Take a guess.
Two?
One?
3.5 billion years ago,
OK?
So, this is really remarkable.
We think it didn't,
I mean, of course it took a
long time because were talking
about millions of years and
hundreds of millions of years,
but still, if you look at the
big picture, it didn't actually
take life that long to evolve on
the planet.
So, why do we think that is the
case?
What's the evidence for that?
Well, we look into sedimentary
rocks, so old rocks that arose
from sediments,
what you find around this time,
you find that chemicals start
to appear, organic molecules
that really resemble organic
molecules in modern life.
So, we have sort of chemical
tracers, or chemical fossils.
00:04:47<clear/>
So, tracers that indicate the
presence of organisms.
But what we also find is
so-called micro-fossils,
and I have a picture of that
here where when you actually
take rocks and actually slice
them into very,
very then slices,
you can put them under specific
microscopes.
And what you then find is that
many rocks that are very,
very old, have those kinds of
inclusions in them.
And these things really
resemble very much modern
prokaryotic cells,
modern bacterial cells,
for example.
And so, those micro-fossils are
generally taken as an
indication, also,
that life is already present
during those times.
Now, when we take a quick sort
of overlook of the evolution of
life on the planet,
again this graph here
summarizes sort of the last 4.6
billion years or so when life
originated.
We see that there was a period
of chemical evolution,
and then somewhere here that
region, it's,
of course, not really well
understood when that exactly
happens, the origin of life is
placed.
But I want to alert you to a
couple of really,
really critical steps here that
are shown on this graph which
we'll actually talk more about.
It is thought that life very
early on is split into three
major lineages:
the bacteria,
the archaea,
in what is called here nuclear
line.
And I'll come back to that in a
minute or so.
Then, a further major event
which you may remember is
oxygenic photosynthesis actually
evolved --
-- which means that
cyanobacteria evolved that
started to produce oxygen as a
byproduct of photosynthesis.
And that really fundamentally
changed the chemistry of the
Earth.
It actually became an oxidizing
atmosphere.
And what you see here is,
once the oxygen concentration
goes over a certain level,
it allowed the development of
an ozone shield.
Now, what does that mean?
What was the critical
significance of the presence of
an ozone shield?
Does anybody know?
What does it block out?
Anybody remember that?
What's the big significance of
the ozone hole over Antarctica
for example?
It allows UV radiation to heat
the Earth's surface,
and in fact if there were no
ozone, the UV radiation would be
so strong that there would be no
life possible on land.
So, once the ozone shield
actually developed,
organisms could conquer,
basically, the land's surface
and settle on the land surface.
In this, then,
is thought to be at least
correlated with the development
of endosymbiosis.
And I'll explain what I mean by
that.
But it basically led to the
origin of modern eukaryotes,
so your ancestors essentially.
But there was still a long
time, obviously,
until humans appeared.
We have here the origin of
animals and metazoans,
and then the age of the
dinosaurs is already a very
small blip here on this graph.
And humans don't even get
featured on that because we are
so recent.
So, but what I want to show you
here is that three major
lineages evolved early on.
These are the bacteria,
archaea, and what we call a
nuclear lineage.
And the significance of those
nuclear lineages is that it
basically combined with bacteria
to form the modern eukaryotic
cell.
So, the eukarya,
or eukaryotes they're also
called.
And it was this combination
that we called the endosymbiosis
event.
I want to explain this a little
bit more, and then I'll show you
finally why we actually know
that those things are very
likely to have occurred a long
time ago.
Yes?
It means the bacteria and the
nuclear lineages combine to form
a eukaryote, OK?
And I'm actually going to
explain this on the slide here.
So, if you have any more
questions after that,
please let me know.
So, again, this shows you this
early evolution,
this early split in two
archaea, bacteria,
and this sort of nuclear line.
It is thought that this nuclear
line, this was single celled
organisms that increased in cell
size, and then developed or
partitioned the DNA into a
nucleus, basically.
So exactly how you find it in
modern eukaryotic cells.
But then what happened is the
cell took up a bacterial cell,
and over time this bacterial
cell became symbiont.
In fact it became the
mitochondria.
And so what this mitochondria
now does in the moderate
eukaryotic cell as you all know
is it really took over the
energy metabolism.
So, the proto-eukaryotic cell
took up a heterotrophic bacteria
that form the mitochondria.
And this ultimately then gave
rise to protozoa and to
modern-day animals.
But there was a secondary
symbiotic event.
This cell, once it had taken up
a heterotrophic bacterium,
it took up an autotrophic
bacterium, a cyanobacterium,
an oxygenic photosynthesizer.
And this actually that led to
the development of modern algae
and modern plants.
So what we can say is that
mitochondria our ancient
heterotrophic bacteria --
00:12:13<clear/>
And the chloroplasts are
ancient cyanobacteria,
so, oxygenic,
photosynthetic bacteria.
And these obviously have
coevolved to then form animals
and finally your plants.
So now, obviously we are
talking here about events that
happened a very,
very long time ago.
And so, the big question is
really how do we really know
this?
But this takes me to the third
topic, which is that of
molecular evolution.
So, we can state the problem
again,
And that is very simply put,
evolution is incredibly slow,
OK?
And therefore,
its processes are not directly
observable.
00:13:47<clear/>
And we need to actually use
inference techniques to
reconstruct evolutionary
processes.
Now, what do we use when we
want to reconstruct the
evolutionary history of animals
and plants usually?
Anybody?
Fossils.
Exactly.
So you take a shovel,
essentially,
and dig down into the different
layers.
And there's different
techniques that you can actually
determine the age of different
sedentary rocks.
For example,
and then you can construct,
if you're lucky,
you'll find enough fossils of a
particular lineage.
You can reconstruct the
evolution of the lineage.
I'm sure you all have seen the
example of the horse,
for example,
where we have actually quite
good evidence when ancient
horses look like.
And we can reconstruct the
sequence of events that led to
the evolution of modern-day
horses.
Now, you can imagine,
though, that when we talk about
such ancient events like these
there really is no fossil
record.
OK, so what people have figured
out, then, is that that was
really a stroke of genius that
came about in the late 60s,
that DNA molecules can act as
evolutionary chronometers.
00:15:00<clear/>
OK, now what do I mean by that?
I mean that you can take DNA
sequences or gene sequences from
different kinds of organisms.
Based on those gene sequences
you can reconstruct the
relationships to each other.
You can determine whether two
organisms are closely related or
whether they are only very
distantly related.
And the underlying mechanism of
that, is that mutations happen
with a certain probability all
the time.
So, the idea is that as time
passed on, DNA molecules will
change.
So they will accumulate,
actually, mutations,
and so this will lead to,
and that the idea is that the
amount of change in a particular
DNA sequence is proportional to
the time of separate evolution
of two different lineages or two
different organisms.
So, the amount is more or less
proportional --
00:17:26<clear/>
-- to time since the last
common ancestry.
00:17:42<clear/>
So, let me explain how this is
actually done.
What you really need in order
to do this, is you need genes
that are related to each other,
OK?
So, genes, they need to be
universally distributed.
That meets all organisms that
you want to compare need to have
this type of gene.
And, those genes need to have
conserved function.
00:18:41<clear/>
In these genes,
we can then compare to each
other, and I will explain how
this is actually done.
Any questions so far?
OK, so the example that I
actually want to bring is the
16S ribosomal RNA genes.
00:19:09<clear/>
We oftentimes abbreviate this
rRNA.
Now, does anybody remember what
the ribosomal RNAs are and do?
What's the ribosome?
Yes?
Right, and what does it do?
Exactly, it's the location
where messenger RNA is
translated into protein.
Now, the ribosomal RNAs are an
integral part of the ribosome.
They play both a catalytic role
as well as a structural role in
the ribosome.
And so, fundamentally,
because this is such a
fundamental organelle,
all living organisms possess
it.
So, all organisms have it.
So this allows us to use these
genes to really compare all
living organisms to each other.
OK, so this is a very important
point.
I wanted to show you a,
OK, if it wakes up.
There we go.
An example of these ribosomal
RNA genes, now this is actually,
what you see here is a
secondary structure of the
actual RNA, the ribosomal RNA.
Now, these molecules have a
secondary structure because they
play a catalytic and structural
role.
And so, the really amazing
thing is when you look at the
structure, the structure
determines really the function
of those molecules in different
organisms.
And then look at this.
We have here a bacterium,
and here are an archaea.
Now, if you think back to the
first couple of slides,
what I showed you is that those
organisms have not shared a
common evolutionary history for
about four, or so,
billion years,
or 3 billion years,
excuse me.
But, if you just glance very
quickly at the structures,
you see that they look very
similar to each other.
So, there's an indication that
the function is really very
highly conserved of those
molecules.
However, when you actually look
at the sequences in detail,
what you'll find is that
there's different regions.
And I'd given some examples
here denoted by A,
B, C in those molecules.
And these different regions of
the molecules are really the key
to its usefulness in figuring
out the evolution and ecology of
many organisms.
The region number A here,
or denoted by A,
a sequence stretches that are
the same in all living
organisms.
So they are universally
conserved, which means that if
you get a mutation in a gene in
that particular region,
you are dead.
OK, that's why it's conserved
essentially.
Then we have those regions B
where the length is conserved,
but the sequence is not.
So, there are sequence change
allowed, but the length needs to
be conserved.
And then there's the region C
were neither length nor sequence
is actually conserved,
and where we get a lot of
variation.
So, let me write this down.
We have three types of sequence
stretches.
00:22:49<clear/>
We have A, what I called the
universally conserved sequences.
We have B where length,
but not sequence is conserved.
And, we have C where neither
length nor sequence is actually
conserved.
00:23:33<clear/>
And the first two stretches,
the first two types of sequence
stretches, are very important in
figuring out the phylogeny or
the evolutionary relationships
amongst organisms.
Whereas the sequence stretches
number C because they vary so
dramatically,
are very important in
identifying organisms.
And we'll talk more about this
actually next time.
So what can we actually know do
with those sequences?
Well, the first step is we need
to generate an alignment.
00:24:29<clear/>
OK, and this is actually shown
here, where each row denotes a
gene from a particular organism.
OK, so these are all
abbreviated here.
These actually aren't ribosomal
RNA genes, but other genes.
And that what you will see here
is we can recognize those three
different regions that I've
pointed out before.
You have the regions A which
tell you which nucleotides line
up with each other,
so you use this sort of as an
anchor because the sequences
never vary amongst organisms.
And that the sequence region B
where you light up sequences
that vary or stretches that vary
in sequence but not in length.
Now, why is this important?
It's important because you have
in each column that nucleotides
that have originated from a
common ancestral nucleotide,
and whose variation over time
you can actually monitor.
Is everybody with that?
Any questions?
OK, great.
The second step,
then, is the calculation of a
similarity.
00:26:04<clear/>
And this is shown here.
Again, we have a very
simplified alignment now of four
different organisms.
Here, we have the sequences
that we want to compare.
And what you'll see is that
they're overall very similar,
but there are different sort of
nucleotides.
And so, what we simply do is
for each pair of sequence
combinations,
we calculate the sequence
similarity value.
So, what you see is that you
have 12 nucleotides,
and the first pair differs in
three nucleotides.
OK, so that tells us,
or it's called actually a
distance here,
I'm sorry.
Let me write this down here.
00:27:01<clear/>
It's simply one minus the
similarity, of course,
but so basically a quarter of
the nucleotides differ where
it's between A and C,
a third of the nucleotides
difference on.
OK, so you do this for each
pair of sequences,
excuse me.
The third step,
then, is to calculate the
correction for multiple
mutations affecting the same
nucleotides.
00:27:54<clear/>
Now, you can imagine that over
time there's a probability that
a particular nucleotide mutates,
say, twice.
So, in the first instance it
may change from A to a G,
, but then it changes to a C.
But when you look at the
modern-day sequences,
you don't know that this
actually happened.
And so there's ways to
statistically estimate what the
likelihood is that a sequence
actually contains such multiple
events.
OK, and this,
we called, a corrective
evolutionary distance then.
And what you will note is that
the corrected evolutionary
distance is invariably larger
than the actual observed one.
Now, what can we can do with
those distances?
We can constrain them into a
best fit tree of relationships.
So, we can draw what we call is
a best fit tree.
That's shown here.
We have our four organisms,
but when you look at those
branches of the tree what you'll
see is that they add up roughly
to the correct evolutionary
distance here.
So, between A and B we have
0.23 and 0.08,
which roughly gives you 0.3
here, OK, whereas between A and
C the tree is constrain such
that we have 0.31,
and here 0.15,
and so overall you roughly get
the distance here that we have
calculated.
And so what this means is that
you ordered the organisms by
their calculated evolutionary
distance.
And so you have now obtained,
actually, a very intuitive
picture of the relationship of
organisms to each other where A
and B are obviously the most
closely related ones,
and A and D are the most
distantly related.
Is everybody with it?
Any questions?
OK, now, this best fit tree is
what we call a phylogeny.
00:30:31<clear/>
Now, excuse me,
these techniques really
revolutionized the study of
evolutionary relationships,
and one of the things that it
allowed us to do is to construct
universal phylogenetic trees or
what we can also call the tree
of life.
And I will show you this on the
next slide, and that I want to
make a few general statements
about this.
So first of all,
when you analyze all known
organisms, and obviously that
would be a big task,
but representative of all known
organisms, what you'll find is
that, indeed,
we have three major lineages:
the bacteria,
the archaea,
and the eukarya.
OK, so we have what we call
three domains of life:
the archaea,
bacteria, and the eukarya.
So, this really is the evidence
that life really split very,
very early on into those three
lineages that I showed you
before.
Interestingly,
two of those major domains here
are prokaryotic,
OK?
So, two of the domains are
prokaryotes.
Moreover, if you actually look
at the types of organisms that
are on here, you'll notice that
even on the eukaryotic side of
the tree, most of the organisms
here are actually microbial.
So, the single celled
organisms: and that means that
most of the life on the planet
is microbial.
The vast diversity of organisms
on the planet are
microorganisms.
So, we can say that most life
is microbial.
And when you,
then, look at analysis of
mitochondria,
and chloroplasts which all have
their own genetic machinery,
and therefore also their own
ribosomes you'll see that the
mitochondrion,
OK, and the chloroplasts both
tree within the bacteria.
So, we really have an amazing
confirmation of this
endosymbiont theory which
actually developed in the
absence of gene sequences by
some Russian scientists in the
early 20th century.
So, we have that mitochondria
and chloroplasts tree within
bacteria, and this really
supports the endosymbiont
theory.
So really, you could say
eukaryotes are really just
walking, and swimming,
and flying incubators for
bacteria, right?
So, just hosts for
microorganisms.
OK, so basically you can,
what you should take home from
this is the three domains of
life.
Two are prokaryotic,
and even more so most of the
diversity that we find is
actually microbial,
and then finally the
endosymbiont theory is actually
confirmed by those phylogenies.
Now, what I want to cover in
the remaining time,
is how we can actually use now
those sequences to learn
something about organisms in the
environment.
That's the topic of molecular
ecology.
00:35:32<clear/>
To introduce this,
I just want to show you a
couple slides that really sort
of capture what the big problem
is that we're facing here.
Now, when we look at the
abundance of prokaryotic cells
in different types of
environments,
what we see is that there is an
enormous number of different
prokaryotes out there.
This summarizes,
here, different types of
environments.
We have the marine environment,
freshwater environment,
sediment and soils,
subsurface sentiments and
animal guts.
And that this number here gives
you the average number of
prokaryotic cells either per
milliliter or per gram.
And it here we have the total
number of cells obtained by
multiplying the average number
with the total volume of the
particular environment.
So what you can see is that in
the marine environment,
we have an average half a
million cells per milliliter of
water, OK?
It freshwater,
we have about a million cells.
What is that telling you?
There's a ton of prokaryotes
out there.
What you go swimming,
you take a little gulp of
water: you've probably eaten
several million prokaryotes,
that it's nothing to worry
about because what this also
tells us is that very,
very few prokaryotes out there
are really pathogens because
otherwise you'd be sick all the
time.
Now, in sediments and soils,
in as little as a gram you have
five times 10^9 prokaryotic
cells almost.
5 billion prokaryotic cells are
out there, and even in very,
very deep sediments that reach
down to 3,000 m,
you have a substantial number
of prokaryotic cells.
Well, and here's your guts,
10^5 times 10^6 gives you 10^11
per gram.
So again, you're just a walking
incubator for a very complex
microbial community.
Here's the global abundance.
You see that steeps of surface
sediments and the marine
environment, probably in terms
of numbers at least,
the most important microbial
environments.
Now, faced with this enormous
abundance of prokaryotes out
there, very important question
is how many of them are out
there?
Or, how diverse our prokaryotes
in the environment?
That's important if you want to
figure out their function and
the environment,
and want to understand also
their evolution.
And what I want to show you
here is that we've gone through
an amazing development in our
understanding of prokaryotic
diversity in the environment
over the last 10 to 15 years or
so.
Who knows about E.O.
Wilson here?
One person?
So, he wrote a very famous book
on biodiversity,
which was published in 1988,
where he tried to summarize,
really, how diverse the known
organisms are on the planet it
also try to extrapolate to the
total diversity.
And what you see is that he
came up with about 1.4 million
different species here,
mostly dominated by insects.
That's the big section here on
this pie chart.
The plants: very important.
And if you look,
the prokaryotes feature with
about 3,500 different species.
So, in 1988 we thought there
were very few prokaryotic
species out there.
If you look about 10 years into
the future and take the
assessment here,
and this just exemplifies how
the thinking has changed,
you see that we think now that
there is about 11 million
different species out there,
and that the vast majority of
them are prokaryotic,
OK, 10 million.
So, this big part of the pie
chart is really the prokaryotic
diversity.
Now, what really has changed is
that we've actually started to
use molecular techniques to
determine the diversity of
prokaryotes in the environment.
So molecular ecology is really
the use of molecular gene
sequences obtained directly from
the environment --
00:40:29<clear/>
-- to learn about the diversity
prokaryotic --
00:40:46<clear/>
-- diversity out there.
Now, this slide just quickly
summarizes this.
Basically, the idea is that you
go out into the environment and
collect either water or soil
samples that,
as I just showed you,
invariably contain a lot of
different prokaryotic cells.
You then lyse the cells and
purify their DNA.
And so that you end up with a
mixture of DNA that represents
the organisms out there,
and then you can use universal
PCR primers to actually amplify
ribosomal RNA genes from all the
organisms that are present in
your samples.
Now, why can you use universal
PCR primers?
Well, they target the regions
number A that I showed you
before.
Those regions in the genes are
invariant amongst all organisms.
You guys all remember how the
PCR works, right?
We cover this.
OK?
Yes?
No?
Who doesn't?
You don't?
All right, come to the board.
Just kidding.
OK, you should look it up.
I don't have time to cover
this, unfortunately,
but basically it's a technique
that allows you to amplify
specific types of genes millions
to billion fold.
And once you have done this,
what you can do is that you can
purify the genes on gels,
and then separate them by
cloning them into individual
plasmids.
And those plasmids have been
inserted into E.
coli cells, and the E.
coli cells are then
individually grown up so that
each culture contains only a
single plasmid,
and you can then sequence these
ribosomal DNAs or ribosomal RNA
genes from those clones.
And so, you have obtained a
library of the ribosomal RNA
genes from the environment.
So, we use environmental
ribosomal RNA gene libraries
from which we then can actually
compare how many different types
of genes are out there.
So let me show you an example
of this.
What we have done recently,
we've gone out in one of the
first really comprehensive
samplings of coastal bacteria
plankton, which means the
bacteria that are present free
living in ocean water.
And so, we've done this,
we've collected all those
clones, and then basically we
constructed those phylogenetic
trees that I showed you before
that really allow us see how
many different types are out
there, and how closely related
they are to one another.
And what we found is that in
this environment that you think
might be very simple because it
just the water column right?
No, not much structure in
there.
We found over 1500 bacterial
16S ribosomal RNA sequences to
occur, so an enormous diversity
of prokaryotes of bacteria in
that particular environment.
And the important point is that
when you actually look at a
collection of such studies that
I just showed you,
what you find is that the vast
majority of microorganisms in
the environment have never been
cultured.
So traditionally what we do of
course to learn about
microorganisms when you grow E.
coli, or so,
you throw them onto culture
plates.
You make lots of different
cells, and that allows you to
study some of their properties.
But when you look,
for example,
at results from the ocean,
this summarizes now coastal and
open ocean environments,
again, the bacteria plankton is
those free-floating bacterial
cells in the water.
And you compare this to what
we've actually been able to
culture from those environments.
What you see is that you have
some dominant groups here.
They have all funny names,
most of them,
because they're just clones and
clone libraries.
But these are the dominant
groups that show up in clone
libraries.
Here's their relative
representation in different
clone libraries from a variety
of environments.
And so here you have one very
important one,
the SAR11 group,
or this one,
the SAR86, that always show up
in clone libraries.
But we've never see them in
culture, so the important point
to realize here is that what is
actually happening is that
whenever we go out,
we find a great diversity of
bacteria out there,
but we have no idea what they
actually do.
And this is one of the big
questions that we need to answer
to understand,
really, how the planet actually
works.
What are those uncultured
microorganisms out in the
environment really doing,
and what is their importance?
And we'll talk about this next
time.
We're going to talk about
environmental genomics because
essentially what we can do now,
is we have techniques available
that allow us to isolate and
least large fragments of the
genomes, sequence those,
and look at what kinds of genes
they have present.
And that allows us,
then, to infer some of their
function in the biogeochemical
cycles in the environment.
OK, so with this I'm going to
close today unless you have any
more questions.